[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec une actualité vous le savez très
chargé pour en parler joséphine colvin
super g bonjour vous êtes merde plaisir
vous êtes vice présidente du conseil
général et vous êtes l'une des mères qui
est allé voir le président de la
république en fin de semaine dernière
pour l'expliquer peut-être la situation
de peau tant d'autres points de vue on
va reparler dans quelques instants à
côté de vous dire charles lajoie ni
bonjour je vous êtes éditeur on va vous
montrer le dernier dernière production
production dans quelques instants mais
je préserve d'abord stéphane mensonge en
quatre jours la diversité de versailles
saint quentin et anne-charlotte bezina
c'est bien moi voilà il est maître de
conférences à l'université de rouen et
assure ce sciences po donc on a beaucoup
de choses à dire je présente donc le
squelette ou là jusque là de rimbaud je
les pollueurs voilà c'est un très bon
roman policier papa policier mais
presque et ce passage eric peut-être non
c'est politique c'est un peu policiers
ces essais littéraires c'est astucieux
c'est une balade une fantaisie
littéraire qui repose sur la décision du
maire de charleville mézières
villa y par un baume à bocaly la kids et
essaime en fait tout est originaire et
le maire décide un beau jour de de
redynamiser le musée rimbaud et donc
libre il faudrait faudrait qu'on fasse
quelque chose et si on exposait le fémur
de rimbaud voilà et ça démarre la vallée
après ça va être très compliqué sur le
squelette de rabot etc on part pour une
grande balade qui va de charleville
mézières à roche et en passant
évidemment par marseille lille a été
hospitalisé s'est longtemps de
squelettes de rimbaud de jean michel
lecocq voilà alors évidemment voyez une
actualité très chargée mais peut-être
avant je voudrais vous demander votre
sentiment sur le sur le pays tel qu'il
est la france tel qu'il est entre entre
l'attentât terroriste de strasbourg le
mouvement des geôliers jaune
cette france vous la trouvez comment
déprimé et désabusé déchiré mois ceux
des prix mais vraiment je suis effondré
par peut pas parce que ça veut dire
parce que ça signifie par l'attitude des
gilet jaune par l'attitude de la presse
et de l'intelligentia des vidéos et des
jo nous voilà et parce que ça induit par
ce que ça parce que ça veut dire de
l'état de la france et de l'état des
défenses est absolument effrayant et des
primes aux 100 en premier du terme
alors après se rajoute à ça
effectivement l'épisode de strasbourg où
la f10 une petite lueur jédir d'espoir
parce que il ya comme une sorte d'unité
nationale qui sert fait derrière
derrière ce qu'elle commente raziq
comment jusqu'à quand on va voir jusqu'à
qu'on va voir de monsieur il ya un tweet
de rêve de raffarin qui est vraiment
bien crédit à propos de la police merci
merci je dis est pavé samedi à baisser
mais c'était oui c'était aussi assez
fait tousser jarris d'être assez juste
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est elle est
quand même déchiré sa tête divisé aussi
cette fausse oui aller elle est alors
divisée je ne serai pas d'hier mais
l'impression qu'il ya plusieurs france
oui il ya plusieurs france il ya une
vraie souffrance d'ailleurs on peut
constater que même le mouvement des jeux
légers légion entre paris et la province
sabato notamment rien à voir pour avoir
rencontré certains gilet jaune devenant
province on a senti par le vrai
ras-le-bol de ce qu'ils évoquent
mais aussi une fatigue une fatigue
humaine non seulement par le mouvement
lui-même puisqu'il en était à dire
qu'ils en étaient à la soupe populaire
et qu'il se faisait aider pour pourquoi
le biais de leur apporter des vêtements
donc c'est un mouvement qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec celui de
paris qui semble je dirais plus porté
par les médias par quelque chose de très
violents avec les casseurs gallas mais
ça n'a strictement rien à voir
et c'est vrai que ça fait une forme de
séparation et je crois que c'est ça qui
est la difficulté aujourd'hui de ce
mouvement c'est de comprendre un petit
peu doux enfin je veux dire d'où ça
vient véritablement et pourquoi les
choses sortent de cette façon et cette
division l'art sans précédent mouvement
tellement disparates que lui-même ne
sait pas forcément qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est son unité en parlant avec
eux ne se rencontrent ils n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes jeuland deux pas du tout
du tout les mêmes demandes
djamen et ces femmes là dessus
je regrette également ce climat un peu
délétère qu'on est en train de vivre
mais qui correspond finalement un climat
que moi je qualifierais de plus européen
c'est à dire que finalement on n'est pas
les seuls à être un pays endetté un pays
avec une fiscalité qui en hausse avec
finalement une menace terroriste qui a
jamais été aussi haute donc brisé un
populisme l'attend elle fait le
parallèle des années 30 ans et mesurer
sa véracité au pas mais on est dans une
période contrarier du monde finalement
et je trouve que la france ne s'en sort
pas si mal dans le sens où finalement ce
mouvement d gilet jaune recherche son
unité mais on sent profondément que il y
à un moment où tout le monde est un peu
un gilet jaune dans une partie de ses
revendications et qu'on peut arriver à
se retrouver
donc j'ai envie de porter le message de
l'espoir finalement essayons un petit
peu notamment avec le strasbourg on l'a
dit on essaye en tout cas de maintenir
une unité d'un point de vue politique
et puis on essaye de le faire aussi avec
les gilet jaune en essayant de voilà de
donner un élément de réponse à ce
mouvement qui qui a des aspirations de
voilà de misère sociale de crise qui
font entendre d'une oreille
bienveillante une annonce c'était
vraiment son moi je je je pense que tout
cela dit beaucoup de la sphère politique
puisque tout ça est une forme de
débordements incontrôlés f et très
globalement et là c'est incontrôlable
avec une je ne dis pas la classe
politique je n'aime pas ce terme là
parce que j'attendrais tout le temps a
marqué une espèce d'anti l'adhésion
lunatique pèse d'aristocratie pénétrer
la sphère politique c'est gpara
l'échelon local au moins pour l'avoir
déjà fait c'est pas si compliqué que
cela
donc je ne critique pas la classe
politique master me la met en tout cas
disons la sphère politique a été
incapable de se saisir de toutes ces
questions si ces questions ou débordé
c'est que la sphère politique ne s'est
pas fait l'écho pas suffisamment ou pas
correctement et je déplore aussi
l'attitude très irresponsable de
beaucoup de grands élus nationaux j'y
inclus mélenchon le pen wauquiez le
président hollande jeu ça franchement
j'ai été enfin ça m'a je trouve
absolument incroyable
pour pâques pour ne pas dire plus
totalement totalement totalement
indécent voire ex nettoyable absolument
et j'ai fait j'ai l'impression qu'on
pourra peut-être dire à un moment un
moment là les élections européennes se
profile que tel est pris qui croyait
prendre parce que je lisais hier dans la
presse que deux alors je ne sais pas
comment dire de mouvements de gilet
jaune envisage est constitué des listes
pour les élections européennes et alors
là mélenchon et le pen et vieri jaune et
front national est de la france a soumis
ce qui y voit là qu'ils perdraient le
plus la cote est exactement mais mes
autres autant autant d'ailleurs la
sphère politique que dès que des
syndicats eux-mêmes qui qui qui ont
alors le berger a eu une attitude très
constructive il a été hélas entendu a
été en tout cas c'est un peu tard le
mans
sache enfin j'ai trouvé et puis c'était
ça correspondait au moment où la cfdt
est devenu le premier premier syndicat
en france mais voilà moi je vois ça
soufflait en effet miroir renvoie à
notre un autre million les faits oui
peut-être alors peut-être mais c'est
vrai que les politiques qui prennent
fait et cause enfin qui l'ont soutenir
les mouvements ne se rendent pas compte
que c'est des mouvements qui sont contre
eux mêmes des contrats des partis
politiques d'une façon générale alors
voir venir peut-être sur appelé les
causes afin de ses idoles 1 va y être
des causes économiques évidents il ya
aussi outre est frappée quand on entend
les témoignages des causes sociales ont
l'impression que c'était des gens qui
étaient qui vivait une situation
difficile dans une sorte de solitude dès
qu'ils ont alors il faut des braseros
comme ça qui se réchauffe peut-être un
peu ensemble autour des ronds points
serait il a fait sa place côté là oui
c'est tout à fait ça mais je rejoins un
petit peu ce que vous disiez sur sur le
lien avec les élus
on a senti un vide sidéral à ce moment
là sauf cette récupération vous évoquez
par rapport à certains de nos grands
politiques qui veulent récupérer ce
mouvement et qu'il y arrive pas quelque
part c'est plutôt bien je dirais mais on
a un vide qui fait que ça devient une
forme d'anarchie
moi j'ai vu dans le regard même de
gérard larcher une échange avec lui qu'
il ya une vraie inquiétude parce que
justement il n'y a pas de structuration
de ce mouvement qui sort et tu n'es pas
habitué à ça on n'est pas habitué à ça
il faut pas prononcer le mot de
jacquerie mais à un moment donné ça vaut
la peine de je dirais de s'inquiéter
fortement
c'est pour ça qu'il est important que le
contact à l'élu je dirais de territoire
de vienne c'est un principe fondamental
on l'a senti yavuz il n'y avait aucune
présence concrète à ce niveau là
1 c'est pas il ya des travaux seller
gilet jaune
justement afin qu'il y avait là juppé
disait c'était enfin il reparle de ce
qui se passait en 95 et dia mais il y
avait un million de personnes dans la
rue ce qui est quand même beaucoup plus
que les 130 milles ou même 200 milles
dans la plus grande des des
configurations qui a eu avec des jo 2010
et il y avait des structures avec qui
discuter salle à rien à part le problème
c'est que c'est qu'il n'y en a pas et
c'est que comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure il ya aussi des des
revendications assez contradictoires cf
je crois que c'était jean tirole le prix
nobel d'économie qui disaient les gens
vont au fond veulent le plus détails -
mais en même temps c'est assez
représentatif pardon de je dirais de ce
que notre président a mis en place c'est
à dire que son ascension au pouvoir si
je peux me permettre a aussi détruit
toute une série je dirais de deux
groupes politiques qui se sont auto
détruit ou enfin bref fit de toute façon
ont disparu d'une certaine façon et ses
essais seulement comment là on est quand
même dans en france dans un besoin de
démocratie avec un peu caricatural ou
mais de droite de gauche avec des
extrêmes
mais ce sont des partis qui qui je dire
porte aussi notre société quand ces
partis disparaissent
enfin du moins non plus c'est ce pouvoir
sacré sacré raison exactement et une
angoisse assise forte
ils n'ont pas ce que c'est alors c'est
vrai c'est vrai combat après on va
reparler peut-être de l'homme
l'importance justement démerder des
politiques de terrain mais c'est vrai
que cette mobilisation par facebook
puisque c'est essentiellement par ce
réseau là qu'elle sait qu'elle s'est
faite ça pose quand même un problème
pour la démocratie telle qu'on la
connaît en tout cas jusqu'à présent
mais avant même le problème de facebook
il ya quand même un vrai problème de
démocratie c'est à dire que d'abord je
pense qu'on a tous tout le monde sur
réagit le nombre de gilet jaune sera la
simulation ça c'est quand l'effet
spécial c'est à dire qu'ils ont des
médias là l'essentiel
et ça c'est déjà une chose qui était
très très bizarre et puis deuxièmement
pourquoi ton probablement sur réagi
parce que ces gens se conduisent comme
de véritables fasciste à dire que
faisons des barrages soient des
ronds-points dire qu'ils ont trouvé
effectivement sûr je reconnais que c'est
très astucieux mais je veux dire avec
quatre personnes on arrive à bloquer
quasiment 2 de deux sorties de ville et
là ils sont là dans toute impunité en
train de vous obliger à porter un gilet
jaune à les applaudir ou à klaxonner
sinon on peut pas passer à ccc des
mouvements qui sont totalement sous des
militaires c'étaient les quelques morts
quand même oui les argos a insultés on
voit pas on avait rigolé sur l'ia il ya
un an mais hier il ya aussi c'est de la
violence entraîne violent fin quand ce
sont des routiers et des gros bras qui
est qui qui barrent la route avec un 38
tonnes tout le monde est là en train de
dire oui c'est des gros fachos ce tu ne
montes et cetera ils sont avec leurs
nerfs de bleu etc
c'est la même chose on exactement dans
le même cas de figure terre qui bloque
il emmerde tout le monde est alors il ya
une spécificité française c'est à dire a
consisté au début parce que les
principes les principales victimes des
gilet jaune
la majorité des commerçants etc au début
tu es là ah oui mon les soutiens c'est
magnifique s'extasiait n'a maintenant
ils sont tous en train de pleurer là bas
woods est peut-être un peu trop soutenu
dsk d'érable face à était quand même une
donnée importante le parce que il y
avait en effet une mobilisation qui
était pas énorme et même en europe où
l'inde considérée comme relativement
stable mais appuyé par un soutien de 60
65 70 % jusqu'à 80% de la population
c'est ça peut-être qui a fait que
mais dépasser 50% en fait on n'a pas
parlé de 80 % puisque 50% de gens qui
soutiennent et 30% en plus qu'ils
comprennent
voilà donc c'est très facile additionne
des choux et des carottes fois qu'on
fait une belle sous faisait avait pas
80% des gens et nous agirons quand même
soleil des réseaux sociaux est là et la
démocratie on est on est habitués une
sorte de démocratie représentative quand
même à face nôtres c'est notre
philosophie c'est vrai que ça change
tout non mais ça peut avoir un effet
très positif
oui les réseaux sociaux nous dire être
alors j'y crois pas à la démocratie
seulement je n'y crois pas mais j'y suis
vous n'êtes pas pris sur pause et la
démocratisation peut pas marcher ça
marche pas le monde n'est pas la suisse
et encore il ya deux cantons de un
canton et demi qui pratiquent en était
de recréer l'agora la normale dans le
privé la lgv aura greg grâce aux grâce
aux réseaux sociaux
je suis au regret à l'agora grecque y
avait 5000 citoyens
oui mais plus mais et des matraques et
des femmes et des et qui tout cela est
absurde et qu'elle avait l'épaule
[Rires]
je vous disais non mais c'est vrai que
sa chose sa chance quand même l'un sur
ses achats il animera singes agissements
permanent un jaillissement continue de
tout est alors de conneries épouvantable
de conclure on entend beaucoup quand
même
et les gens ont peut-être tendance j'ai
pas certaines personnes c'est comme vu à
la télé abbassi facebook le dit c'est
que c'est vrai quand même c'est qu'il
n'ya pas de fumée sans feu etc
ça peut être très grave et les théories
du complot qui sautent ils sont
multipliées après l'âpre l attentat de
strasbourg 10 ans oui comme par hasard
mais mais c'est ce que vous disiez c'est
à dire que en effet macron et passer un
petit peu au dessus des partis
politiques des cornes de ce qu'on
appelle façon générale les corps
intermédiaires mais est ce que ces corps
intermédiaires sont quand même pas en
crise
d'une façon générale c'est ici si les
gilets jaunes se réunissent comme ça
c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas de syndicat
pour les représenter
il a appelé les syndicats sont d'une
faiblesse absolue non ya une crise
évidemment elle et elle et elle est
évidente les partis politiques évoluent
beaucoup moins vite que la société du
problème il est un peu là c'est que la
société vous par vos paniers des réseaux
sociaux mais c'est vrai que là oui je
dis pas que c'est une évolution d un
changement s'est déroulée et on le
ressent d'ailleurs au niveau de même du
contact avec la population
sur le terrain les réseaux sociaux
donnent des raisons donne des
explications donne des évidences qui
sont difficiles ensuite à gérer et les
partis politiques ne changent pas aussi
vite c'est une espèce de grande lenteur
avec des remises en questions qui sont
très compliqué très difficile donc il ya
une perte de vitesse donc ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a on a
deux corps qui ne s'accorde pas et il va
falloir que les partis politiques
prennent conscience de ça en ayant
vraiment la sensation que tout ne vient
pas d'eux on n'est plus dans ce côté
pyramidale on parle là on parle souvent
de concertation avec la population
on n'en est plus là on en est à la
co-construction aujourd'hui c'est ce que
demande la population je vous le dis
parce que sur le terrain nous on le voit
il ya encore quelques années on venait
avec un ou deux projets en disant qu'est
ce que vous préférez avec des
modifications
aujourd'hui on vient avec une page
blanche et ont construit ensemble sinon
ça ne passe pas c'est la démocratie
participative de ségolène royal c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué c'est ça que
je peux vous dire c'est compliqué la
question des corps intermédiaires à mon
sens et c'est là que je vous rejoins
complètement
à mon avis c'est la population qui n'ont
qui n'en veut plus en quelque sorte
c'est à dire que ce n'est même pas les
partis politiques ou les associations
les syndicats qu'il n'arrive pas à se
structurer suffisamment vite c'est
l'utilisation de facebook live elle est
là c'est cette idée de dire tout sera
directement à qui est tout de suite et
ce qui a finalement lisez le mouvement
c'est cette ce temps politique qui
aimons relativement classique pour nous
qu'il étudiants - 11 10 - un président
qui met deux semaines intervenir aller
ça peut réflétant long mais ça devient
aujourd'hui inacceptable que ce ne soit
pas au bout de 24 heures peut-être par
rapport aux médias on l'a dit aussi
voilà avec l'aller le journalisme en
continu ça a changé ce rapport à
l'information n'en a parlé pour des
enquêtes judiciaires cesse tout doit
être beaucoup plus direct et je pense
que ce que vous disiez de la
co-construction c'est même un mouvement
assez différent la démocratie
participative où normalement vous amener
une décision fait que vous faites plus
ou moins ratifier ou en tout cas vous
vous organisez des plateformes qui ne
sont pas forcément directement associé à
la décision
c'est cette fois ci cette idée de comme
tu le disais finalement de revenir à une
démocratie directe c'est-à-dire c'est le
peuple qui décide c'est lui qui doit
pouvoir utilisé par n'importe quel média
les pouvoirs décisionnels qui sont
réservé à quelques-uns et finalement
l'organisation même d'un système de
représentation administratifs politiques
syndicales devient on a le sentiment en
tout cas d'après ce qu'on entend de ce
mouvement de
un intolérable alors cette coupure entre
peut-être le pouvoir central et puis la
population vous avez essayé d hépatite
d'y remédier en tout cas dont parlait
avec le président de la république vous
avez fait partie des maires qui avec le
maire de poissy avec le maire de saint
germes en allées sont allés à l'elysée
je crois que c'était vendredi soir
dernier
comment est née cette cette initiative
déjà très rapidement il y avait un
contact entre monsieur karl olive asie
qui connaissait que te voilà et puis des
remarques que nous avons pu faire
personnellement j'avais aussi envoyé un
message au président en lui disant que
l'invitation qu'il avait faite à
l'elysée de réunir tous les maires ne
m'intéressait pas et il la forme que je
préférais que je souhaitais comme bien
d'autres mères c'était de lui parler en
directement tout ça a fait que en
l'espace de 48 heures des choses se sont
faites et que le président a demandé à
ce que au tour de karl olive puisse se
mettre je dirais quelques maires et que
nous allions voir mais de façon avec un
postulat d'ascq était de parler cash et
de se dire les choses sans protocole est
vraiment de façon très concrète c'est ce
qui s'est passé nous sommes nous avons
été accueillis à l'elysée vendredi après
midi au lieu de rester une heure et
demie de sommeil c'est trois heures avec
une écoute
attentive sereine humble vraiment en
face d'un président qui attendaient que
nous lui évoquions tous les sujets qui
faisait je dirais aujourd'hui la
difficulté de ce que nous vivons nous au
quotidien en tant que maire nous sommes
venus pas du tout pour revendiquer quoi
que ce soit au niveau de nos
collectivités
mais pour parler dans un haut niveau
sens large
et d'ailleurs nous avions chacun aux
thématiques a évoqué au président pour
que ce soit plus organisés et plus
respectueux à son encontre et nous avons
eu des réponses pas ferme et définitif
sur des choix qu'il allait mettre en
place le lundi d'après mais en tout cas
on a pu entendre dans ses propos de
lundi qu'il avait entendu certaines
choses puisque il s'est fortement appuyé
sur les mers dans ses propos en disant
qu'il allait s'appuyer sur les mers il y
rencontrer également évoqué le fait qu'
il avait blessé pas mal de personne je
vous le dis parce que c'était
mathématiques la thématique d'un garde
de sa communication secteu mans et de
son image la deuxième le président
d'alors de mépris que pouvaient
ressentir le rendement avec des propos
vraiment trop les soirées bleus sont
huit mois je ressentis comme tel notre
ressenti comme tel d'ailleurs il l'a
évoqué et il a accepté que je peux là je
parle de moi en tant que personne
vraiment de lui dire des choses très
très franc je lui ai raconté même une
anecdote qui s'était passé à bougival ou
son entourage nous avait demandé
d'enlever la les sharks et que nous
avions très interprété en tant que maire
ce que je considère aussi comme un
affront bien sûr ce n'était pas de son
fait à on en est bien d'accord mais et
puis tout ce qu'il a pu évoquer comme
propos et puis également le fait que mon
bref j'ai fait des petits comparatif
avec un président qui doit être dans
l'empathie et que nous les français on
est quand même des latins et qu'on a
envie d'apprécier le président et que je
me suis permis de lui dire se fit pas de
nom on vous demande pas de caresser le
cul des vaches de l'ancien président
mais voilà des choses à faire et il a
accepté vraiment tout ça n'est pas ce
qu'est ce que les photos de données de
cette entrevue 1
oui oui on était des mères oui
pratiquement tous républicains aux non
inscrits et donc on s'était dit avant
d'y aller que l'objectif était pas de
taper sur le président mais c'était
d'échanger avec lui et à partisans oui
mais par l'opposition mais c'était
vraiment un discours à politique un
discours d'une remontée vraiment et
surtout de dieu et d'essayer de recréer
une confiance auprès du président en lui
disant que aujourd'hui nous avons frais
dans la sensation qu'il est hors sol qui
n'est pas entouré de députés qui sont
intégrés peut-être après 2000 des
mandats parce que c'est peut-être une
des aînés enfin on parlait va quitter
famille et de très beaux mais c'est très
étonnant parce que au fond il sortait de
deux semaines d'une dizaine de jours ce
qu'on avait les peler l'itinérance
mémorial avait le côté bien le real mais
il y avait le côté heated en hausse et
je vais rencontrer les français sur le
terrain mais au fond je ne sais pas on a
l'impression que cette rencontre avec
les français n'a rien donné d'abord kim
pas compris ce qu'on me disait et
peut-être qu'il a oublié d'avoir cet
intermédiaire vous parlais tout à
l'heure de la volonté comme ça du but
d'aider des populations davodeau de
participer mais peut-être que la parole
des mères elle est importante que d'être
un peu plus synthétiser plus comprendre
mieux comprendre quelle est justement
cette aspiration
je pense que les maires ont encore un
minimum de respect la part de la
population qui n'est pas le leur c'est
la seule fonction au cowboy qui s'appuie
comme on lui a évoqué on voudrait pas
partir avec l'eau du bain dans de cette
mouvance de regard de la population
vis-à-vis des élus qui voilà qui met
tout le monde dans le même panier
je peux vous garantir que 99 portion des
élus se donnent corps et âme à leur
fonction donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une vraie difficulté par rapport à
cela c'est de ressentir de ressentir que
nous avons encore un rôle à jouer au
niveau des mers on ne le sens plus ça
faisait quelques mois quelques uns
et que nous savions la pression parce
qu'ils me le demande ne s'attacher plus
à nous je dis pas une colère ma famille
mais de votre part enfin quand même eu
l'impression d'être un peu laissé de
côté quand même fait mépriser le mot est
fort c'est vraiment le ressenti que nous
avions qui n'est pas certainement
volontairement voulu par le président
mais en tout cas qui étaient mis en
place par son entourage
je crois profondément et nous penchons
nous les maires qu'il a un entourage qui
n'est pas fait d'élus qui ont un vécu
cette amende de technocrates quand même
avec le reste on peut avoir mais il lui
manque ce lien avec la population que
nous avons au quotidien on est apportée
dans glanant le dis nous je parle de
nous et on peut faire remonter ces
informations c'est ce que nous avons
évoquées au président je crois qu'il l'a
entendu et qu'il l'a compris puisqu'on
n'était pas là comme vous le disiez
madame sûr je dirais un apport
politiques ont des propositions c'est
une démarche c'est ça et je crois que
quand on parlait de démocratie directe
tout à l'heure quel que soit le modèle
comprennent quand on suit souffre ou le
reste on a quand même toujours l'échelon
local qui revient comme étant le plus
légitime aux yeux de la population est
comme celui qui représente le mieux
finalement le corps un petit peu en
dessous du niveau national et qui peut
permettre de faire circuler des
informations plus concrètes puisque
finalement cette idéologie de la
déconnexion de la sphère politique dont
dont nous parlions au départ elle elle
est portée par le caractère comme vous
le disiez technocratique finalement
d'aidé grande élite alors que les maires
de france sont encore
attaché à ces réalités et sur un terrain
avant la proximité donne beaucoup de
sincérité
l'épreuve de la technocratie c'est comme
ammann des vrais problèmes non de ce
pouvoir
un peu entre choisir entre la peste et
le choléra parce que la technocratie ce
n'est peut-être pas terrible il et gilet
jaune c'est tragique n'entache pas le
pas dans ses yeux mais ces deux là parce
que là jour elle m'a le gilet jaune à
les écouter mais n'ont surtout pas parce
que c'est c'est le degré zéro de la
discussion de la pensée et de réunion et
de la proposition non mais c'est une
véritable quartier totalement des propos
comme ça mais quand on les noms mais une
revendication général mais le choix
n'est pas entre les gilet jaune et les
technocrates et spatiale entre les
technocrates et des lutins
voilà c'est vrai que côté qu'aux mères
convenant mais presque les départs de
colomb du gouvernement le fait qu'ils
pas beaucoup de politiques dans ce
gouvernement
le fait quand même du super pouvoirs du
secrétaire général de l'elysée du du
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
qui sont des gens très compétents
peuvent personne de personnes
mais c'est vrai que voilà on est bon et
pep dans une dans une coupure de cette
relation cela au paradoxe dans marche
parce que vous en parliez en marche
quand il s'est créé n'était même pas un
mouvement politique n'était même pas
constitué comme parti politique ce n est
pas meilleur de la crise des particules
avait organisé des marcheurs locaux des
anciens l'ancêtre des gilet jaune et
bleu ou le mammouth 1 c on est dans le
marcheur local qui vient porter et
c'était le seul candidat qui n'avait pas
de programme pendant très longtemps
parce qu'il avait dit ce programme
remontera des initiatives citoyennes
donc ce n'est pas la technocratie pour
dire justement on a besoin de gilet
jaune au parlement ce n'est pas mon idée
mais emmanuel macron avait porté cette
idée que la démocratie n'était pas
réservée aux élites et que donc il
fallait qu'elle reparte d'un socle et
finalement ce que les gilet jaune mairie
ce public aujourd'hui c'est alors si le
socle n'est plus en accord qu'est ce
qu'on fait et c'est la question qu'on se
pose c'est qu'on a organisé un régime
représentatif administrativement
localement politiquement qui fonctionne
très bien
mais quand on a une déconnexion
populaire finalement avec la voilà le
vert et dans la benne comment faire dire
des députés en mars ce sont des gens qui
viennent de la société civile qui se
veut démocratique
il ya quand même une et je crois que me
il ya une inégalité tels que les enfants
d'ouvriers ne peuvent pas accéder en
euros aux grandes écoles
encore moins qu'avant il ya vaillant une
aggravation de ce point de vue là des
des inégalités donc ça existe vraiment
comment dans la société
non oui enfin je pense pas encore une
fois que ce soit le plus le principal
souci des principales revendications des
villes et zones de non mais ça fait
partie de ça fait partie peut-être
d'aider des sentiments un peu diffus
comme ça mais qui une égalité dans la
société qui est des injustices ça fait
partie aussi
je crois que ça faisait partie de
beaucoup de nos de nos confrères
européens de nous des pays qui nous
ressemblent beaucoup ont basculé dans
dans le populisme notamment au niveau de
leurs élites parce que précisément les
nouveaux élus ont utilisé facebook
twitter un discours très différent
beaucoup plus direct avec monsieur avec
des liens étroits avec les italiens faut
le voir mais gorman on a cette idée que
nous la france on avait réussi à y
échapper par une forme de populisme un
peu un peu malin qu'avait organisé
emmanuel macron dix ans je viens de la
base mais je vais quand même nettoyé et
recréer quelque chose de voilà de
technocratique aussi et finalement c'est
une sphère sa balle est ce que ce
mouvement a encore une possibilité de
fonctionner alors je ne suis pas pour
une solution institutionnelle de
destitution de je crois qu'en tout cas
il ya une question à se poser sur la
connexion de ce mouvement avec sa base
qui était son postulat d'existence donc
il est par exemple une contradiction
une de plus absolument énorme dans le
monde les jd the past comportement des
bleus mais le
la principale revendication c'était faut
supprimer le sénat et cie s'il ya bien
un lent je sais pas ce qui leur a pris
tout d'un coup pensé à cette heure ci
voulait que mais le vivier deviennent
bien s'il ya bien une entité politique
qui connaît un peu le terrain qu'il
reconnaîtra pas ces territoires et donc
c'est totalement contradictoire c'est
encore une fois se tirer une balle dans
le pied c'est à dire que c'est
franchement on peut reprocher beaucoup
de soul mais larcher sur des
revendications on est on est à peu près
tous d'accord
maintenant je reviens quand même au non
cumul des mots bakhit qui espère grc pas
de bon sens mais beaucoup défi dix
bennes peut-être que ces députés qui
vaut pas le droit d'avoir d'autres
mandats sow un peu coupé quand même de
la population s'attaquera absolument
incroyable et inaudible pour moi c'est
ce qui empêche un député qui n'est que
député d'être présent dans sa
circonscription et le son ils sont à
l'assemblée du mardi au jeudi
qu'est ce qui empêche un député d'être
comme les maires à porter d'engueulades
moi j'aime bien cette expression parce
que c'est ça qui est important
mais oui qu'est-ce qu'il en peine d'être
apportées d'engueulades au supermarché
au marché dans la rue etc
moi mon député je le connais laissez pas
sa fonction bardon il s'est pas sa
fonction la fonction et réalisation d'un
réseau cotation va pas représentants de
ça c'est vrai j'ai longtemps que ça ses
fonctions mais on va c'est cette assise
locale dans le district law dans les
faits on a droit c'est passos et sociaux
non non je ne comprends pas je n'ai je
n'ai jamais compris cela comme si les
députés étaient en permanence enfermé au
les bourbeau alors on dit - cela des
sénateurs et que de temps en temps il
passait la tête en apercevant la
populace les gilet jaune et cetera
diantre de quoi s'agit-il une révolte
non une révolution terrain mais surtout
tout cela est une construction est un
discours construit rien n'empêche un
parlementaire d'être d'être et puis de
fréquenter ils le font pour la plupart
d'entre eux de se fréquenter
régulièrement les maires les conseillers
municipaux les élus locaux les
conseillers départementaux
enfin hier face à des débats est revenue
à 7 je suis pas tout à fait d'accord il
faudrait c'est normal non mais c'est pas
j'ai l'impression qu'on a on a mis en
place ce dispositif de façon un petit
peu démagogique parce que ce qu'on a
entendu c'était oui les maires et les
députés dessinateur surtout quand tu me
lis en mettre plein les poches
non mais on l'a entendu et donc du coup
ça a été un petit peu une base de
discussion
oui certes ils sont ils sont sur le
terrain pour certains est certes ceux
qui avaient un cumul de mandats maire
député ou maire sénateur avant il y en
avait qu'il n'y était pas
donc tu peux dire je suis pas un procès
d'intention ni aux uns ni aux autres
je dis simplement que il ya un
apprentissage de l'élu de terrain et
l'apprentissage de l'élu de terrain il
commence pas forcément par conseiller
municipal adjoint au maire etc
mais n'empêche que je peux vous dire
qu'un conseiller municipal ne fait pas
le travail d'un adjoint yan adjoint fait
pas le travail du maire et quand vous
allez ensuite ou au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale vous devez avoir
quelque part une connaissance de tous de
toute cette trajectoire la quitte une
trajectoire qui est complexe parce que
quand vous êtes élu vous connaissez tous
les secteurs d'une collectivité
quand vous êtes député vous arriver
effectivement il y en a qui se donne
beaucoup de mal moi j'en connais sur ma
circonscription je n'ai aucune critique
à faire sur leur investissement
mais ils sont malgré tout déconnecté il
leur faut un temps incroyable
pour rentrer dans le concret alors que
quand vous venez de du monde de l'élu
c'est pas pareil vous êtes tout de suite
dedans donc ce qui fait que pour voter
des lois
vous êtes un petit peu déconnecté alors
si ma vision puisque moi je suis dedans
vous voyez est très bien la magie fait
que et je lui dis en toute transparence
puisque monsieur larcher l'a même écrit
sur une lettre dans le journal communal
on m'a demandé d'être sénateur aux
dernières élections j'ai refusé parce
que je ne pouvais pas cumuler donc j'ai
préféré rester maire je m'étais engagée
à ce niveau là mais il est vrai que je
me dis comment en venant de la société
civile tout à coup je me retrouve
sénateurs où je me retrouve députés et
il va falloir que je prenne des
décisions ça me semble compliqué je dis
pas que c'est impossible mais ça me
semble compliqué donc ça éloigne encore
plus ici je peux me permettre au niveau
de l'intercommunalité c'est un peu
pareil aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe on éloigne aussi les mêmes de
leurs responsabilités on n'a pas
suffisamment travaillé la subsidiarité
ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui les
intercommunalités prennent pouvoir sur
des compétences locales et des
compétences de proximité qui auquel ils
ne peuvent pas répondre de la même façon
et avec la même exigence que la
proximité
je revendique haut et fort le fait de
laisser aux mères une vraie
responsabilité de terrain et de
proximité pour en prendre plein la
figure
on est très proche d'eux au fond de
leurs actes et au niveau des
intercommunalités et bien de travailler
sur les grands dossiers structurants du
territoire mais pas sur le quotidien je
sais que gérard larcher il travaille et
monsieur bakr on l'évoqué aussi cette
idée de subsidiarité
c'est important si vous me permettez
jeunes un tout petit exemple je suis
allé en angleterre a love stuff où on
était jumelé j'étais content de
rencontrer le maire il avait une ville
de 80 mille habitants la mienne fait
trente-deux mille je me suis dit je vais
apprendre des tas de choses il me dit ah
mais moi madame le maire jugèrent 20000
euros le reste il gérait là haut je ne
vois rien oui mais il avait une très
belle chaîne avec quatre médailles
il a fait le protocole i 12 accueilli et
quand je lui dise que nous avions
compris
qualité il n'en revenait pas et il m'a
dit mais au moins vous pouvez répondre
il dit nous on est là que pour le
protocole si c'est ça qu'on veut faire
en france moi je dis attention
le peuple français n'est pas prêt
peut-être dans cinquante ans les choses
ont évolué pour le moment on n'en est
pas là la preuve en est c'est que voyez
la montée de violence qui a eu ces jours
ci cette dernière semaine
proulx véritablement que on ils ont
encore besoin d'être écoutés ils ont
encore besoin d'être écoutés vu
d'ailleurs comme ça c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont jaunes oui non mais c'est vrai il
ya surnommé mais il ya ça il ya dedans
le seul
l'idée que personne ne les écoute et
peut-être que justement parce qu'on a
rogné vous le pouvoir des maires et
leurs capacités
il ya une autre fonction alors qu'ils
étaient au débat en cause
en tout cas on demande des choses
contradictoires c'est la fonction du
président de la république
on a presque lui donne l'impression qu'à
un moment les gilets jaunes demande et
disait mais alors pourquoi c'est pas on
n'a pas un président normal quoi
rien non mais c'est vrai c'est pas la
fonction c'est la personne qui est en
cause que c'est la personne comme avec
françois hollande comme ce fut le cas
aussi avec sarkozy alors peut-être oui à
peut-être qu'au delà de la personne
c'est un peu c'est peut-être un peu la
fonction j'en sais rien mais c'est quand
même des choses très content évidemment
on y obtient une cristallisation de 2,2
de haine de maigret d'entraînement des
draps de trucs complètement irrationnel
et qui sont fins qui sent qu'ils sont de
l'ordre du scandale enfin ça n'est pas
acceptable de minutes le il ya aussi une
fonction de représentation le mais on
parlait tout à l'heure de représentation
là on parle de crise de représentation
entre nous c'est comme si c'est un truc
récent la crise de la représentation
elle est inhérente à la représentation
elle même en 1991 déjà on s'était posé
la question de savoir qu'est ce que
c'était que représenter est-ce que c'est
signifier le la présence d'un absent ou
est-ce que c'est vouloir comme est-ce
que c'est vouloir pour ou est-ce que ces
douleurs quoi voilà pour pour résumer
les choses
donc de cette contradiction la de cette
crise on n'en sortira pas mais sauf
qu'il n'ya pas d'autre manière de faire
fonctionner une démocratie telle que la
démocratie française avec un système
représentatif on peut mettre un peu à
titre d'adjoint un peu de participation
autant qu'on voudra mais la
représentation est indépassable
oui mais regardez comment on a tendu
alors le président critiqué parfois à
eacom vous disiez en tout cas très
plutôt mal par l'opinion et combien en
même temps on attendait sa prise de
parole comme si ya des risques que c'est
en voyant le fait qu'il parle pas dans
la minute qui suit j'avais là mais
j'avais une nouvelle définition de la
vème république c'est une monarchie est
dans laquelle on coupe la tête du roi
tous les endroits où c'est vrai qu'on
attend quand même beaucoup encore de
président comme moi je crois que la
fonction présidentielle si on prend pas
le texte mais là la philosophie un petit
peu de nos institutions la fonction
présidentielle c'est une fonction
presque social sociétal c'est à dire que
cette figure là elle est aussi une
figure en tout cas tel que l'a voulu le
général de gaulle est tel que finalement
ils ont quand même assez bien perpétrer
les successeurs ont parlé tout à l'heure
des vaches je ne sait plus à quelle
occasion exactement mais on avait un
jacques chirac qui a repris un capital
pas possible avec le salon de
l'agriculture parce que du coup bon il
savait se montrer
c'est loin mais c'est beau voilà on a on
a gardé de ces images on le quitte alors
qu'il avait d'autres défauts on peut pas
dire qu'il était dans une situation de
cohabitation qui est quand même
politiquement la plus tendue c'est là
qu'il a réussi avec ce capital sympathie
finalement récupéré un petit peu
popularité de mitterrand beaucoup plus
loin pas en revanche mitterrand beaucoup
le matin mais là aussi avec une fonction
arbitrale assez forte c'est à dire que
la situation de conflit sachant naviguer
et finalement on va donner du moulin à
jean-charles là dessus c'est il ya une
nouvelle contradiction de ce mouvement d
gilet jaune qui est celle d'avoir su
révéler à la fois le fait que toute
cette nouvelle élite était censé être
plus représentative mais que comme elle
n'était pas formé comme vous lisiez aux
réalités du terrain et je crois que
c'est également ce dont a souffert
emmanuel macron alors sa jeunesse
numérique n'est peut-être pas à mon sens
le
la cause de cela mais il est un petit
peu de bois vert à ce niveau là et il
n'a pas su finalement incarner ce côté
paternaliste en essayant simplement de
rassurer d'écouté à partir des premières
heures de la de la contestation qui ne
nous aurait pas amené à cette communauté
que vous avez évoqué autour des braseros
finalement si dans les premières heures
on ne s'était préoccupé que de l'atp
ice1 qui était le seul problème au
départ est supprimée en journée lui
peut-être déjà dix mille euros se pose
dans le budget ce qu'on était quand même
acceptable et un président qui n'a pas
su finalement anticipé peut-être par
manque d'expérience des crises sociales
et des dialogues maxi barrios par
volonté de dire moi j'irai au bout de je
veux pas faire toi je devrais pas faire
comme les pouvoirs précédents
c'est aussi probablement parce que c'est
un président qui fait déjà d'abord il
fait ce pourquoi il était élu il avait
promis des sous et il vient ce qui tient
ses promesses
vous parliez de jacques chirac jacques
chirac il est très sympathique c'était
merveilleux d'aller sûrement boire une
bière avec une dans un café enfin en 12
ans à part la suppression du service
militaire il n'a strictement rien fait
pas la moindre raison et mâcon est en
train de payer les de l'inaction de
trois prisons de la république précise
henri mais parce que vos voix arrêtons
de trois ans ses mémoires chirac c'est
qu'il je crois qu'ils avaient des
obsédés par le bas 68 vous savez
continuer à les négocier les accords de
grenelle et qu'il est d'y aller armes et
discuté avec la cgt et je crois qu'ils
avaient une peur bleue de la révolution
ça ces évolutions d'une grippe est bon
voyons ce qui se passe aujourd'hui après
tout est ce que cette analyse était
était aussi une énorme salle mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait on a et d'autres notamment
la révolte vote au sein d'un monde
meilleur
c'est la patate chaude sa réponse était
dans ce cas là on ne fait rien est-ce
qu'il a traité un meilleur volontaires
pour lui il a parfaitement jobs a tout
ay un tout petit dernier mot c'est qu'à
mon sens emmanuel macron et tout son
gouvernement à reculer
donc finalement à quoi servait-il à quoi
cela servait-il d'aller faire arriver le
premier ministre au 20 heures qu'elle
vient de dire nous ne changerons pas
d'un iota alors que finalement presque
toutes les revendications une par une
sont tombés et c'était ce qu'il fallait
lui éviter à mon sens plus tôt c'est à
dire que plus il a tardé plus il a été
obligé de lâcher du terrain et cette
gestion on en revient tester leur combat
veloppement beaucoup de technocrates en
autorail blement quand on lui ouvre pas
intelligent peut pas comprendre
certaines personnes et certaines actions
c'est à dire que la logique voulait que
rien ne se passe comme ça se passe de
l'intelligence jeudi mais ce n'est pas
possible
puis en fait si ça devient un peu ça
vient hélas possible mais donc on est un
prénom grappiller des manières vous
l'avez vu est ce qu'il était vous l'avez
trouvé touché par justement ce qu'ils
entendent et sur lui sur fond une sorte
de désamour enfin en tout cas il était
il était sincère et je vous le disais
tout à l'heure très humble mais je
rejoins ce que vous disiez il a quand
même évoqué le fait qu'il qu'il qu'il
récupère tout ce qui s'est passé
précédemment
il est oui il est aussi dans un ré cents
ont donné voilà deux problématiques
antérieur oui c'est pas cette année ces
deux pannes et fière de ce mouvement va
tous les connaissons bien sûr et il
assume complètement il l'a quand même
révoqué non pas pour se justifier mais
en tout cas pour évoquer qu' il n'avait
pas peut-être toutes les responsabilités
et là je peux en train de le défendre on
va dire c'est non non non il avait passé
macabre
mais cette étape mais ça c'est bien
justement d'avoir des contacts avec les
gens c'est alors ya évidemment le
discours de lundi soir et est-ce que ça
a convaincu alors on a un sujet je crois
que c'est déjà des jaunes qui était quoi
nière justement et qui était pas très
convaincu par par les propositions du
président de la république un village de
gillet jeunes à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle démarré à coignières des
citoyens avec des situations sociales
différentes tous mobilisés contre la
politique du gouvernement
nous on commence à prendre racine il ya
une chose qui a apporté ce mouvement et
et indirectement le président c'est une
solidarité
il a réussi à voile a rassemblé quand
même pas mal de demandes et on commence
à se créer une petite famille gilet
jaune et de ceux qui soutiennent à
travers un barrage filtrant les gie les
jeunes s'organisent pour faire vivre
leur mobilisation ce matin des élus de
coignard sont venus leur rendre visite
après l'installation d'une benne à
ordures par les services municipaux pour
voir quelles sont les quels sont les
besoins fait faire en sorte avant tout
que ça se passe bien aussi bien pour eux
que pour les automobilistes qui passent
s'il ya une volonté de donner la parole
aux français aux citoyens par
l'intermédiaire des mairies on le fera
enfin ça me paraît une évidence
augmentation de 100 euros du smic prime
d'activité comprise défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou suppression de
la hausse de la csg pour les retraites
inférieures à 2000 euros
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron est jugée insuffisante
beaucoup de personnes ici je sais que
j'ai rencontrés m'ont bien fait
comprendre que voilà c'est ça suffit pas
ça suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir d'achat voilà c'est juste vivre
j'ai entendu c'est un premier pas qui
est intéressant maintenant il ya
tellement tellement tellement tellement
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés qu'au final en fait c'est du
vent je le prends comme ça sert que
quand on quand on est sur une
intervention médicale et qu' il ya une
hémorragie on met pas un pansement
on sort les gros moyens et on sauve la
personne cj les jeunes ont prévenu ils
sont prêts à passer les fêtes ici en
famille à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle des marais de coignières
voilà donc à des gilet jaune un peu
divisée dans l'ensemble pas très
satisfait on a deux twin d'ailleurs qui
reprennent un petit peu ça il ya celui
de benoît hamon qui dit le compte n'y
est pas sur le social même si la lutte
on paye et oblige ma crois bouger un peu
les riches et les entreprises polluantes
past encore entre les gouttes et peuvent
dormir tranquilles pas un mot à la
jeunesse mobilisée pour ses études se
signale que benoît hamon a soutenu quand
même les casseurs et 1
on va reparler après et un tweet de karl
olive alors qu'ils étaient avec vous à
l'elysée tous les élus républicains de
droite comme de gauche souhaite que la
france gagne le mouvement doit prendre
fin
moi je voudrais peut-être lancer le
débat sur un point c'est que je trouve
que l'on s'est beaucoup plaint justement
de cette figure présidentielle un peu
absente pendant les deux heures de crise
à partir du moment où la parole a été
prise et où un effort a été fait et où
justement un recul a été quand même
considérable
1 parce qu'on il faut le chiffrer ça
fait presque 10 milliards d'euros qui
ont été concédées des mesures qui alors
certes peuvent être qualifiées
d'insuffisantes suivant comment on les
analyse mais qui sont en tout cas dans
le sens de ce qui était attendu
qu'est ce que c'est que la suite de cela
- c'est la question que je me pose c'est
que l'idée était de faire céder le
gouvernement et d'entendre finalement
une réponse à des questions bien
précises en termes de fiscalité de
pouvoir d'achat
maintenant qu'elles ont au moins été
donnée à être à l'état embryonnaire
c'est à dire on a quelqu'un qui en plus
proposer de continuer avec un dialogue
avec les élus locaux
edouard philippe quelques semaines avant
lui avaient proposé carrément un grand
dialogue fiscale également donc quelle
est la prochaine étape qu'est ce qu'il
faut de plus qu'il ya deux voies la
suite une phrase d'aristote qui disait
même si tu ne peuvent me persuade du ne
me convaincra pas si on avait appris ce
que c'était
c'est un peu ça c'est de dire que pas
qu'on propose il y aura de la vraie
bataille elle est pas là et c'est la
bataille de l'opinion
c est ce que l'opinion va continuer à
soutenir ou pas le goût le mouvement
voit bien que ça se fissure un petit peu
en secret un peu je veux qu'on parle
quand même d'un peu d'aidé ce qui se
passe aussi dans les lycées
alors y ait eu on voit ça c'est voilà ce
qui s'est passé à mons que la jolie
notamment
ces lycéens qui était à genoux les mains
derrière le dos alors ça fait une
polémique énorme on a oublié quand même
qu'ils étaient en train de mettre le feu
à des voitures de saccagé une partie de
la ville des relevés des bonbonnes de
gaz ont été ses deux boys et pas des
petits gamins innocents noir le feu
entre les deux lycées oui vous dire donc
c'est quand même absolument absolument
tragique mais là ce ne voit pas ça parce
que benoît hamon les a défendues enfin
je veux dire c'est presque bien ça
rassure que le défendre parce que du
coup on sait de quel côté faut être
alors que ségolène royal avouera les
bons souvenirs bien évidemment en fin de
journée qu'est ce qui est dramatique à
être mis à genoux après avoir essayé
d'incendier la moitié de la ville en
fait si content tout à fait drôle de la
police il ya des filles ont pas de débat
et cela c'est vrai que ça alors après
d'autres lycéens ou dans des
manifestations reprise se fasse au mit à
genoux les mains derrière l'udc
oui mais on est dans la résistance
d'apple dévoile alors là on est tout à
fait comme au chili face à l'aise face à
face à pinochet l'organisme la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme il ya
un petit débat qui se créent dans notre
cénacle universitaire sur la question du
traitement qui doit être réservé
aux mineurs alors il ya toute une
procédure pénale qui est différente mais
pas au moment de l'interpellation qu est
ce qu il faut être particulièrement
précautionneux avec la manière dont on
interpelle nos jeunes la question se
pose et on te pardonne excusez moi mais
ce qu'est ce qui est sans doute un peu
choquant c'est que enfin c'est on est
dans un monde qui comme ça c'est que ce
soit filmé et commentés et s'assoit sur
les réseaux sociaux
cette texture que si l'opération avait
été menée sans qu'on danse une grand
chose personne n'aurait agi là c'est
vrai que le film de ça avec le type qui
dit et j'ai enfin que avec des
commentaires un peu un peu particulier
c'est ça qui est peut-être aussi le pont
de claix l'heure mais sur la fin l'asse
c'est une technique de maintien de
l'ordre jeudi que les forces de police
ont alors cela dit elles sont contrôlées
je lui avais 350 saisine de l'igpn il ya
des plaintes qui sont déposées
certains aboutiront sauf que moi je me
félicite globalement du fait qu'on a des
forces de l'ordre police extrêmement
professionnelle ou de gendarmerie
c'est assez voilà comment oui comment
quatre ou cinq
je sais pas si c'est de la police
peuvent maintenir en respect quelques
minutes l'aider alors des jeunes
l'enfant des jeunes qui en est fait est
fait mais il ya qui a préféré qu'ils
liquident leur tape dessus de voir les
étudiants sans une matraque et c'est
bien cet héros narrateur dé l'argent
mais il ya un truc et qui est révélateur
de ces grognes des délices et enfin le
lendemain de l'intervention du du
président de la république et une
représentante autoproclamé j'imagine des
lycéens qui disent aimer mais c'est
scandaleux
le président n'a pas parlé de nous alors
il faut qu'on continue mais en fait
parler de nous on sait pas pourquoi il
devrait en reparler des visées avait
tout d'un coup on est juste dans un truc
au delà du ridicule que tout le monde
est là qu'on en parle il a pas parlé
mais j'ai été vexé des études il
continue mandé on est chez les fous et
la contestation vient très tard parce
qu'on a des étudiants qui viennent
militer contre parcours sup des lycéens
qui viennent milité contre la réforme du
bas qui ont été toutes les deux à
adopter on me sens avant l'été dans un
silence tout à fait tranquille
oui aujourd'hui hélas l'organisation
d'ailleurs est-ce que c'était un
mouvement de soutien on verrait gilet
jaune est ce que c'est une réforme
contre eux
la réforme elle même on n'arrive plus
vraiment à connaître les revendications
et c'est là que ça car de l'avis de
stéphane doucet
on sait d'où ça vient la manipulation et
des lycéens et des étudiants
le pas peur on a quand même l'impression
que je dirais la population et quelles
qu'elles soient fonctionne un peu comme
les réseaux sociaux c'est à dire avec
des mouvements virulent avec des
expressions violents des retraits des
marches arrières démarche avant c'est
assez inquiétant c'est très excitant
parce que il est probable qu'on ne sait
pas quel sera l'avenir de ce mouvement
la décision mais il est probable qu'ils
aient d'autres mouvements qui reprennent
dans les années qui viennent
pourquoi ça c'est un fait un mot
justement 6 à 6 la situation de ce calme
parce qu'à une ce qui est une solution
politique a ajouté ajouter une crise
politique majeure à la crise sociale
dissolution changent régulièrement
on parle pas de cohabitation douce
plaisir perdu avec un nouveau premier
ministre pour être des rares marchés
parce que ce serait une cohabitation
lady louise ne crois pas que ce serait
une cohabitation nationalement si une
tête saute c'est plutôt celle du
gouvernement
on voit que général c'est vrai que à la
suite du référendum du sur une fin du
référendum sur le wiki a mené un nom de
la constitution pour l'europe c'est le
gouvernement qui a été changé à chaque
revendication sociale on remanie un
petit peu donc c'est normalement le
gouvernement qui a eu un peu raté oui
gouvernement qui a été un petit peu oui
un petit peu un petit peu mal mal
ressentie aussi de penser que c'est le
cas cette année
est ce que est ce que le gouvernement et
le premier qui va sauter bon la question
se pose en tout cas c'est souvent
traditionnellement comme ça que ça se
passe les questions de dissolution peu
voilà 68 on a mis la dissolution qui est
intervenu d'ailleurs après que le
président ait pris la parole plusieurs
fois donc est-ce qu'il faut pas attendre
un échec un peu plus cuisant de la
négociation avant d'en arriver à la
solution la dissolution de ce qu on va
respecter la démocratie enfin le les
élections lieu il ya 18 mois je viens
c'est pour cinq ans dès les élections
législatives en lieu le verdict a été
clair il n'ya pas aucune raison il faut
il faut refuser de rentrer dans cette
espèce de faux débat en redisant macron
démission ce une aberration absolue ya
aucune raison je dirais que les gens se
préparent qu'ils apprennent à lire
qu'ils apprennent à savoir pour qui ils
vont voter la dissolution dans trois ans
et je tiens celui de ce président qui a
été réélu son président qui en aucun cas
qui ont cohabité mais je m'intéresse
convient deux ans et demi m'intéresse
plus à l'avenir de la france gasquet les
galères élégant mais qu' on peut pas
dire que ces dissolutions et apporter un
énorme bien fait à la france ces
périodes de cohabitation dans lequel
plus personne ne fait rien et c'est
certainement pas de fin en tout cas
c'est pas mon souhait donc voilà le but
n'est pas de préserver un tel ou à tête
c'est que la france avancé et que la vie
des français s'améliore
c'est ce que dieu vous entende conclu
après oui oui on verra on verra ce qui
va se passer
pour un l'union nationale justement
qu'ils soient et j'ose le dire et si
vous revenez à l'e10 je voudrais
signaler visite
merci à mon niveau merci à tous les caps
l'émission est terminée a très vite pour
un nouveau numéro de boeuf
[Musique]